of course it's not just the nurses
striking we have a pending ambulance
strike as well which does rather beg the
question taken together is there a risk
to life if these strikes go ahead could
people die as a result
well good good morning we are putting uh
all
um necessary derogations working with
the unions and individual trusts to make
sure that there are minimum service
levels both for ambulance trust level
and indeed at hospital trust level to
ensure patient safety is my number one
priority I know it's the number one
priority of NHS staff I hope it is also
the number one priority of unions those
conversations are ongoing with ambulance
trusts and unions and only the Secretary
State and I have meetings with unions
later today to firm that up sure
calls if they're not attending category
two calls which which is the implication
in parts of the country that that
minimum service level may not be
sufficient I will ask the question again
let me be absolutely clear on that our
expectation is that category 1 and
Category 2 calls are covered they are
considered to be life-threatening or
emergency calls and my call to the Union
as I will repeat later today is that
category 1 and Category 2 calls which
make up around 50 percent of all calls
to the ambulance service should be
covered as part of derogations
the complaint from the part of
specifically the paramedics and it is
that you know people are currently dying
as a result of a service that is
overstretched I mean unite the union
admittedly not not your favorite people
in the world but through a freedom of
information request they discovered that
the West Midlands ambulance trust has
seen an absolutely staggering increase
in patient deaths nothing to do with the
trust in 2020 according to official
figures one patient died in the year
until September that in this year till
September 37 people have died because of
ambulance delays I mean the ambulance
the paramedics have a point don't they
so at the moment the the services below
where we would hope and expect it to be
in part that's pandemic driven it's
largely not down to the ambulance trust
itself but issues actually with bad
occupancy and discharge within hospitals
that's why we've put an extra half a
billion pounds into discharge this
winter opening up an extra 7 000 beds uh
but but on these issues my door and the
door of the secretary of state is is
open we want to discuss these with the
unions I'm having further conversations
with them later today but these are not
issues relating to pay which is the main
issue that is driving the conversations
uh on behalf of the the unions now
anything with regards to patients would
be tens of thousands with tens of
thousands of places you know of course
unoccupied unfilled within the Health
Service I gently suggest that perhaps P
does have something to do with it well
you specifically asked about paramedics
paramedics we have an extra three
thousand last year another three
thousand being recruited this year we
have 40 percent more paramedics and
ambulance staff compared to 2010 the the
issue is actually within Hospital trusts
and we are putting the resource in to
address that to ensure that the Handover
times within hospitals uh come down so
ambulances can get back out on the road
that is not that is not an issue
specific when it comes to ambulance
trusts uh and pay but the the critical
incident declared by the ambulance trust
in the Northeast because you know isn't
it because of the understaffing levels
that that presumably it doesn't follow
to what you were just describing there
so the largest the largest issue is is
around over delays and that that is
largely about bed occupancy levels
within hospitals flow within hospitals
and discharge into adult social care
they are all issues that we are tackling
but we're also building up resilience
within the ambulance trust to an extra
150 million pounds an extra 20 million
pounds uh invested in the fleet and as I
say we are investing in more paramedics
too and my door and the door of the
secretary of state is open when it comes
to discussing those issues around
patient safety and working and
conditions for staff what we are not
willing to negotiate is reopening the
the pay for this year which is part of
the independent pay review body
recommendations which the government
accepted in full you say that your door
is open you say that that of Steve
Buckley's it is open as well
particularly as regards to the nurses
but is it is it potentially possible
that Rishi sunak closed that door and
put his foot up against it when he
stopped your boss from giving nurses a
one-off payment that could have brought
an end to these strikes
I don't think that is the case so where
your right is that the NHS has a a fixed
fixed budget that is that was uh set at
the uh Autumn statement we had an extra
3.3 billion pounds a year and we've got
important issues to tackle including the
covid backlog of around seven million
under patients
are not block a one-off payment no I I
haven't I haven't seen
um any any specific detail around uh
what one of one-off payments but what I
would say is this our door is a door is
open to discuss um with with the uh with
the unions anything relating to working
conditions what we what we can't do now
let's get is go back into reopening the
uh pay uh award which was set by the
recommendation by the independent pay
review uh body we whose recommendations
we accepted uh in full that they will
now be looking to next year as
independent pay review body
recommendations to kick in from April
and let's not forget we're three
quarters of the way through this year
already and any extra extra percent over
the 1400 pounds or average four point
seven two percent a trace to 700 million
pounds
we are also you know Midway through a
kind of a period of extended strikes and
you know perhaps people might want to
get things sorted out I have to raise
something though Richie soon out this
morning giving a rather interesting
interview to the mail in which he kind
of talks about sunachism his kind of
political philosophy and he says this
which I think you know will cause people
to stop and stop and steer the first
thing Mr sumac says that I want to
deliver for people is peace of mind
peace of mind is also about knowing that
public services like the NHS are going
to be there for you and your family when
you need them and then goes on to talk
about waiting lists I mean is Mr like
taking the Mickey
no not not at all and if you if you look
at the most recent Autumn statement it
was exactly that public services that
were prioritized whether it was the
extra eight billion pounds into Health
and Social care or the additional
funding into education that's exactly
where for you and your family when you
need them they're not right now for many
many people because of this government's
refusal to negotiate on pay
uh well look we we have an independent
pay review body recommendation which
we've accepted uh in full it's important
that you have that process and let's not
forget that last year we had the same
process where the recommendation was
three percent when The Wider for NHS
staff when The Wider public sector uh
was was frozen uh that was at the time
three three times higher than than in
inflation
um this year we've accepted those
recommendations in full but it's
important to point out because you you
reference nurses and paramedics but
actually what we're talking about is the
entire agenda for change Workforce which
is 1.24 million people who work within
the NHS they're on this the same agenda
for change contracts so any change
that's why it costs 700 million pounds
for every one percent the the ask of the
RCN of some 19.2 percent equates to 10
billion pounds now I I will I will
however note that at regular points over
the past 12 years this conservative
government has ignored or added to the
recommendations of a variety of
independent peer review bodies I do
however I'm sorry I know you're pushed
per time and I want to let you get away
but I just need to ask you and Sky News
has been running an investigation this
morning about the hunter comb group um
serious allegations of failures in care
we were first reported on this in
October now again another 30 patients
have come forward with with legitimate
complaints it would appear what is your
department going to be doing about that
well I've seen your report it's uh
totally uh unacceptable and if if I were
a patient or a family member of a
patient I would rightly want answers to
that too I know having spoken with my
colleague um Minister Maria Caulfield
who has responsibility in this area she
takes it incredibly seriously and I know
both NHS England and the CQC will want
to look at this very closely indeed
Minister it's great to have you on this
program this morning thanks for joining
us pleasure thank you